the jurgen experience
this modernity i mean the way
human beings represent sexuality or the
way sexuality is represented
um what's wrong with it like what what
are the
what are the key things that stand out
as an evolutionary biologist
um well let me try and experiment with
you okay this is uh
i'm concerned this isn't going to work
but i hope it does even if it doesn't
work it'll work
okay um i would like to try and
experiment with you
as a a red-blooded male
okay i would like you to conjure
the image in your mind
of a woman who is not beautiful but is
hot
okay can you do it sure okay can you
conjure the image of a woman
who is beautiful but not hot
yes no problem no problem me either
this i think actually is a window into
much that is wrong
with what we think about human sexuality
i think most people if you ask them
without doing that little experiment
to conjure or to define
what what it is for somebody to be hot
you would get answers and people would
tell you that hot was sort of like
the height of beauty right which is very
frightening if that's true because
hotness wanes with age it deteriorates
it just can't help it the discovery that
beauty
actually is a different parameter tells
a whole different story about what's
going on with us people with
men and with women and i think both men
and women are confused by this
so if it is true and i i mean i know it
is true i can look inside my own mind
and i can say that at least for some men
it is true that beauty and hotness are
almost uncorrelated there are people who
have both traits
but i uh i have no trouble
seeing that image of a woman who is hot
but not the least bit beautiful
and i know lots of women who are
beautiful and not hot
and i also if i take the category of
women who are
beautiful but not hot um
there are a lot of older women in it
right i know
women in their 60s and 70s
who have poised have aged gracefully
their gray as can be they may be
wrinkled but
if you talk to them one does have the
sense i'm talking to a beautiful person
right and i'm not i'm not being modeling
here if it was just a simple fact that
both beauty and hotness waned with age
i would say so but it is not the case so
what's going on why do we have these two
categories and why do we assume
i mean if you look at advertising you
will get the message
that hotness is where it's at
right hotness is the thing it's the only
standard possible
it's the only standard and so women are
aspiring to it
and then they're fighting it as it wanes
and all of this and
um here's what i suspect is up
because males are males they have
i want to say they have two reproductive
strategies really they have three
reproductive strategies and one of them
is
uh so awful that it's really just
unpleasant to even
enter it into the discussion but you're
talking about rape
yep yeah so the first reproductive
strategy that men have the one that
would generally have succeeded and
by the way we can talk about monogamy
versus
polyamory and all of that at some point
but i'm not
saying anything that is inherent it's
not inherently about monogamy
the way males have typically reproduced
is they have
invested in their offspring and the
mothers of their offspring
that's the go-to mechanism for
reproducing as a human
why because human babies are so needy
that one person trying to raise them on
their own
is hobbled by just the sheer difficulty
of trying to manage
an infant and a toddler while trying to
accomplish the other things of being a
person
so let me just add here the idea that
monogamy has been ubiquitous throughout
human history is not
completely accepted but that there is
good evidence for it on a lot of fronts
and one of the points against it is that
we remain
somewhat sexually dimorphic that men are
on average a bit taller
a bit more must you know much more
muscular but
that we are so much less sexually
dimorphic than
even our ancestors um
you know in more recent times than when
we were we should have
most recent coming assists with chimps
that we are moving towards a
more monogamous situation so just i
think i think you said something that
was unclear at the beginning
there has been a lot of polygeny where
one male has multiple females in human
history probably the majority
of human cultures have been polygenous
yes the majority of people on earth
today
belong to cultures that are at least
nominally monogamous and we should talk
about
what that shift is and what it means to
us and what's desirable and all of that
but
the basic point that human babies are so
expensive and difficult to raise
that you need a team to do it and you
know in part
this is a chicken and egg question is
not a good term because
it's quite clear which came first but um
the
this is a situation where the when you
have a team you can also afford to have
a baby that's more needy and there
there's nothing good about a needy baby
but there is something good about
what you can get if you can tolerate a
needy baby you can get a baby that's a
lot
more nuanced when it grows up so males
have traditionally invested in offspring
but a male who is investing in their
offspring
should they happen on an opportunity in
which a female who is fertile
and capable of producing an offspring
does not require commitment from them in
order to have sex
that's an evolutionary bargain a male
who can
either convince a female or finds a
female who's willing to produce a baby
but not expect any support in return
that's such a power it's like winning
the lottery evolutionary so it would
have almost never happened in history
because
women because babies are so expensive
are wired to avoid this like the plague
you don't want to get stuck raising a
baby on your own if
you could through committing to somebody
get
a partner in raising an offspring so how
does birth control factor into that well
we'll get there in a second but let's
just get the two strategies on the table
males in general have succeeded
reproductively
by investing in their offspring and
their offspring's
mothers when they have the opportunity
to produce offspring with no commitment
they have a hard time resisting that
opportunity because it's such an
evolutionary win
but that doesn't mean it would have been
very common in history because females
would avoid it
so can't look away from hot is about
that second strategy
right so hot is this channel
that men can they
they are wired in such a way that they
actually
we've been robbed of every useful term
they are triggered
by the sight of a woman who is
broadcasting
hotness right and um
so anyway the the thing that i think is
most important about this
is we now live in a culture where we
have
advertisers essentially creating a kind
of insecurity because insecurity causes
people to spend money they
otherwise wouldn't that insecurity has
women
trying to capture male attention by
broadcasting hotness which
of course works because men have a hard
time ignoring hotness
but what i think women often don't
understand
is that getting a man's attention by
broadcasting hotness
has him in the frame of mind of the
second reproductive strategy
and it is actually counterproductive to
getting his attention
for the first reproductive strategy
because
men have historically this is by the way
this is where i'm going to get in huge
trouble
with people because this is going to
sound like an accusation really i'm just
trying to describe
what has been and then we can talk about
what we should do about it but
a woman who values herself
highly in reproductive terms will not
leap on uh a sexual opportunity just
because it's available because what's at
stake is so
great historically for women this is not
true anymore because of birth control
but historically it would be true that a
sexual interaction is basically
baby roulette and baby roulette is a
dangerous game to play
so and so we get at some of what's true
underneath the stereotype of the madonna
[ __ ]
dichotomy that you know
neither of those words is quite right
because no one wants a madonna no one
wants a virgin as a life partner
right you want to have a vibrant sexual
relationship with your life partner
but the are you triggering the hotness
can i get a baby out of you and never
see it
um strategy in men or are you triggering
the
oh my god you're gorgeous and i feel
like we could do this together
i hate to interrupt you but you got to
pull this thing close to you sorry sorry
just
just move that sucker around so it's so
it's comfortable where you're sitting
how about that it's
very different it sounds okay in our
ears but it's very different than the
audio
sorry perfect no good so um so
so anyway the madonna horror complex
which is this famous
thing isn't the paradox that we are led
to believe
men are interested in you know as
heather points out
madonna and horror the wrong terms
they're very charged but
right men are interested in
both of these reproductive strategies
but they are not interested they are not
paradoxically searching for them in the
same individual